[Música]
hablamos de salud en directo América de
France 24 conmigo en el estudio más
Romero sala mar por supuesto vamos a
hablar de estas intensas olas de calor
que siguen afectando el continente
europeo le pregunto sabemos hasta el
momento digamos una cifra general de
Cuántas personas han fallecido sí
Empezamos el día con estas malas
noticias desgraciadamente sabemos que en
España ya han muerto más de 500 personas
entre el 10 y el 16 de Julio que es esta
semana de esta oleada de calor
particular de la que estamos hablando
Portugal también tiene una cifra que son
más ya de 650 víctimas mortales hay
datos menos concretos por ejemplo de
Francia Reino Unido Grecia pero sin
embargo pues podemos afirmar con
seguridad que ya son más de mil las
personas que han fallecido por estas
oleadas de calor sin embargo también
recordemos que estas primeras que se
pueden contar siempre son las muertes
más directas por ejemplo por golpes de
calor pero una oleada de calor una ola
de calor como estas va más allá de estos
efectos concretos que ahora vamos a
hablar sino que también pues al final
sequías provoca incendios que a la larga
tienen efectos sobre nuestra salud
provoca la saturación de los hospitales
de los servicios de emergencia empeora
De hecho también algunas enfermedades
crónicas todas estas todas estas
consecuencias que quizás son más a medio
a largo plazo las vamos a ver también en
los próximos meses Qué significa mar un
golpe de calor digamos que estamos
hablando de qué se trata Sí vamos a
explicarlo Bien también porque así
sabemos cómo prevenirlo no También
básicamente eso sucede cuando hay una
exposición prolongada a unas
temperaturas muy altas haciendo
actividad física o trabajando y por
ejemplo pues con ropa que no deje
transpirar sin estar bien hidratados así
la temperatura corporal aumenta hasta
los 40 grados que es una temperatura
para la que el cuerpo no está preparado
sería el equivalente o incluso más a una
fiebre muy alta algunos de estos
síntomas de estos golpes de calor cuando
el cuerpo se calienta tanto pues por
ejemplo un ritmo cardíaco alterado
náuseas una respiración rápida dolor de
cabeza también por ejemplo puede suceder
que estemos desorientados o que perdamos
el equilibrio Qué es lo que está
sucediendo en el cuerpo Pues que los
órganos vitales están inflamando Están
teniendo una reacción a este calor
entonces se están hinchando y las
funciones neuronales del cerebro no
están funcionando correctamente en parte
por ejemplo porque El hipotálamo es una
parte del cerebro que regula la
temperatura corporal pues haciendo
funcionar mecanismos como la
transpiración como el sudor que de algo
que nos ayuda a mantenernos frescos
dentro de nuestro cuerpo y este
sobreesfuerzo que hace pues impide que
otras funciones sigan su curso de manera
normal esta inflamación estos
desequilibrios pueden provocar daños
permanentes en nuestros órganos que se
vean afectados Y pues si no es tratado
rápidamente si no se intenta solucionar
en el momento puede llegar a provocar la
muerte como ya hemos visto también en
varios casos además también hay algunos
factores brevemente a tener en cuenta
por ejemplo las enfermedades
respiratorias pueden empeorarse porque
la polución también suele empeorarse
cuando hay olas de calor tan intensas
las enfermedades cardiovasculares o
enfermedades como la diabetes se pueden
exacerbar y finalmente hay un vínculo
que todavía no está tan estudiado pero
que hay datos suficientes como para
afirmar que existe entre estas olas de
calor y la Salud Mental por ejemplo
haciendo que durmamos peor o que estemos
más irritables algo que también sin duda
empeora nuestra salud y nuestra calidad
de vida vamos a mirar el futuro mar cómo
va a emplear Cómo va a empeorar estos
fenómenos de las olas de calor pues
sabemos que el cambio climático al menos
a un futuro mediano plazo va a hacer que
sean más y más habituales en nuestras
manos decidir hasta cuándo De qué forma
Pero sabemos que podemos afirmar en los
próximos años esto se va a volver un
fenómeno más habitual de hecho en 2019
ya provocó la muerte de más de 350.000
personas entonces si miramos el número
de personas que están expuestas no el
número de víctimas recordemos en el
número de personas expuestas a calor
extremo y además por días al año es
decir estas cifras es importante que lo
tengan en cuenta puede ser que una
persona esté repetida que está expuesta
a un calor extremo varias veces en un
mismo año varios días en varias olas de
calor en 2030 una Horizonte que ya no
está tan lejano
27.500 millones de personas 30 años
después en 2060
36.700 millones de personas expuestas a
calor extremo también repetimos
multiplicado por los días del año sin
embargo vemos que esto sucede de forma
muy desigual no en la franja en la que
más aumenta es en las clases sociales
más Bajas con menos recursos
representados en el gráfico en rojo
mientras que por ejemplo en el verde
oscuro que son las personas con más
recursos más ricas apenas aumenta entre
2030 y 2000 2060 Así que vemos pues que
las personas Al final que van a tener
más herramientas para afrontar estas
horas de calor pueden mitigar sus
efectos mientras los que están más
expuestos no
Qué hacer para evitar llegar a este
punto de no retorno que yo creo que ya
llegamos Sí bueno primero vamos a hablar
a nivel individual Raúl saber que
podemos hacer cada uno cuando estamos
afectados por estas olas de calor no
Primero que nada pues intentar
mantenerse a la sombra mantenerse
hidratados muy importante Por lo tanto
también alejarse de cosas como el
alcohol que nos pueden ayudar a
deshidratar estar en zonas aireadas
comer más a menudo y evitar la actividad
física en las horas pico de más calor
del día por ejemplo alrededor del
mediodía pero en lo colectivo lo que
tenemos que hacer es hacer un buen
diagnóstico del problema no no todo el
mundo se puede permitir hacer estas
cosas que ayudan a sobrellevar estas
horas de calor como estábamos viendo
Entonces tenemos que actuar sobre estas
personas que están más expuestas más
vulnerables pero por ejemplo evitar que
se trabaje en estas franjas horarias
actuar sobre las personas sin hogar que
no van a tener recursos para protegerse
también Especial cuidado por supuesto
personas mayores o los niños que siempre
van a estar más expuestos y tener
políticas públicas que permitan que los
espacios públicos
espacios de temperatura controlada con
agua potable y además recordar que
hablamos mucho de Europa porque a veces
ponemos el foco mediático más fácilmente
en estos lugares pero lugares como
Pakistán o India llevan décadas
registrando estas temperaturas tan altas
que se están viendo ahora en Londres y
teniendo que sobrevivir a esto entonces
también tener en cuenta que esto es un
problema global y que repartir
equitativamente los recursos va a hacer
Pues que se mitiguen los efectos 100%
mar incluso aquí en nuestra región de
América Latina del Caribe Pues en
muchísimas personas sufren de estas
oleadas de calor insoportables
Muchísimas gracias como siempre mar por
toda la información de salud mañana con
más por supuesto vamos a saludar a
nuestra segunda invitada del día
[Música]